walking back to Glamour with me joshing
Santos and today and ready steady beauty
and Pam the [ __ ] what we do say babes
today we're going to be doing a natural
look okay sort of like can't be bothered
we're gonna make it look like I've made
an effort kind of look my favorite kind
of left there's a lot of products
sometimes I don't use all of them
because I feel like I don't want to put
too many layers of mm-hmm but on a day
where I feel like I need it
maybe you're hungover no and this will
be the first thing I put on first so we
can just called the Kiehl's Irish
extract activating treatment asbestos
I'm not gonna pretend I know how to say
all that I mean there's a lot on the
label how do you actually use it it's on
the screen right now ding gets in your
eyes you go blind are you serious
okay great we are in a department store
right yes let's gather parvis tour by
bar where am i taking myself today oh
nice oh yeah great ever been to Nepal
I'm just gonna make it this is actually
one of my favorite things to use it can
make your skin - only if you wear it
everyday okay but it's really good when
I'm hungover dehydrated I found I saw
him like an alcoholic I'm not it's just
like one of those things that you do
with quite a lot when you're 20 I also
quite like it cuz this is kind of giving
me science far oh my god lab I did this
with my coat she's rubbish just few
drops in the head okay
oh my god I'm definitely back in the
pool now babes yeah yeah yeah let's
let's drop in the pool maybe like barley
how about that
I had everything you can say like book
the Regis Harley we thought that I've
played and I say played I played hockey
and bubble Rangers teach you were you
quite an aggressive hockey player
I was terrible so like I'd be the one
that runs out you like ah once I've got
the ball had no skills there's a real
snack not having any ball skills babe
well not hockey balls yeah right we've
done that oh no Wang look I'm the mix
when you look like you're in Mumbai so
the next is an eye cream what's this
gonna do like awaken my baby blue I find
it's really good when I've got bags yeah
feeling it rubbish bit tired I feel like
it sort of wakes nothing sometimes if it
gets in your eyes well it stings your
eyes and there's definitely away for
that point every cloud has a silver
lining
almost close my eye because you've got
some very fierce nails
yeah I'm sorry they're really sharp so
what we're moving on to now what's the
product also chic top on MTV partner
share yeah tick tick boom taught me
fairy this is really exciting for me
obviously this is pride inspired which
we love which we love I'll supply the
swag
I played bright and pride with Britney
Spears earlier how was that did you get
to meet Brittany of course not MTV
staying alive is in support of HIV I'm
sort of making sure about communities
and people can spread the word about HIV
and prevention of HIV so that's exactly
why it's pride inspired because that's
the community that you know has a lot of
focus on that a lot of face creams are
sort of designed for older people and
nighttime breakouts and stuff this works
for young skin I feel right so then yet
not moisturizer this is a good little
massage bag it's magic babes you don't
look that much different you just look
shinier I think that's a good thing
another look I always go for because
then you just look fresh you like fresh
out the gym you look mean you know just
so naturally gorgeous anyway stop it
you just need a bit of the Juche so
we've got some Armani lip gloss lip
stick here we go oh but if I could get
it right is this what is the beauty
product you feel most empowered by is it
lipstick concealer right stay still
don't talk for a sec I know that's hard
it's gonna be hard
yeah all right all right
[Music]
this is quite a bold color on me i sharp
knife it looks like a moustache at the
moment I thought I was better at this I
thought oh that's why I say this bits
will last well you know what I quite
like a messy lip look because it looks
like you don't care about much and you
just like you know candid cash we like
cash Wow
I'm just really like scared about
putting it on your teeth oh my god what
is that
hug well thank God for the Kiehl's
because I'm glowing everywhere around
you know what the color is making your
eyes pop I kind of look I've snog -
Ronald McDonald yeah you do look like
you've snog somebody I think it's the
new thing it's the light look a bit
disheveled cheery skin disheveled layer
yeah you heard it here first guys
working what's the worst TV question
you've ever been asked like about my
hair which is a really easy thing to
answer it stucks my head you're the one
thing I've really hate is when people
though can I touch it I mean I can be a
piece of art if you like the like when
you go to the museum you don't touch
these yeah and this is the arm this is
our so have you ever had a time when you
would like worried about having curly
hair because I only wish how he was this
talked about my childhood there were no
celebrities when I was growing up with
curly hair so like and obviously
everyone wants to be like Beyonce but
then we all know Beyonce has lots of
hair stylist yes she does yeah I've
always wanted straight hair and a thigh
gap and now I don't want either grab you
little did I know I was on trend from
the day I was born
now shush okay because this is really
stressing me out I feel like I haven't
been able to show off my skills as a lip
makeup artist I feel like you're looking
more like the Joker now well perfect the
heat time for Halloween hard right you
look great though sexy
how would you rate the look that you've
achieved today out 10 I feel like it
wasn't my best execution and it looks a
little bit like when you go to the
counters in a department store go in
wanting one thing come up with another
but it's ok because we've made it into
something we've made it into something
we've made it into a lane inspired look
yes with a touch it's like dewy skin
with a touch of Halloween yeah
so it's layered yeah you can catch more
tutorials on glamour calm
[Music]